عكس بريطانيا واستراليا لم تتحصل بكين على
غواصاتها كهديه تطويرها كان مشروعا وطنيا
صرح موت بان بلاده مصممه على بناء غواصه
نوويه ولو بعد الف عام 50 عاما مرت على
الغواصه النوويه الصينيه الاولى وطريق
استراليا الذي بدا اليوم لن يكون اكثر من
طريق الصينيين والدليل في بنود الاتفاق
ستتسلم استراليا اول ثلاث غواصات عام 2030
بينما تطمح بريطانيا لبناء اول غواصه
نوويه محليه عام 2040 برنامج يمتد لعقود
وهنا تبرز قوه الصين وذلك بقدرتها على
انجاز المشاريع في زمن قياسي عقبه اخرى
اقتصاديه هذه المره استراليا تحتاج انفاق
عشره مليارات دولار سنويا لتمويل المشروع
بينما خصصت لندن سته مليارات سنويا
اقتصاديه واحده قد تنسف المشروع كل هذا
واستراليا لن تتمكن من صنع غواصاتها
الاولى قبل
2040 مشروع مرهون باراده حكومات الحلفاء
المتعاقبه والوضع في الصين مغاير نظامها
يمتاز باستقرار طويل الامد وفره الاموال
والاراده السياسيه لا تكفيان للنجاح
المشروع يحتاج تنسيقا فعالا وتبادلا امنا
للمعلومات اضافه الى بنيه تحتيه نوويه هي
غائبه حاليا في استراليا
[موسيقى]